I am a believer that the truth will
always Prevail and there are other
people out there that believes that
believe that the truth will prevail Elon
Musk is one of them
um you know you do some tweets that seem
to be or at least give support to some
who would call others conspiracy
theories
well
yes but I mean honestly you know
some of these conspiracy theories uh
have turned out to be true
which ones well like the the hunter
Biden laptop that's true yeah yeah so uh
you know that that that was a pretty big
deal there was Twitter and and and
others engaged in active suppression of
the information that was relevant to the
public
um that's that's a that's a terrible
thing that happened that's like an
interference okay so you see what's
going on here guys we live in this time
with sort of oh uh well not that word uh
we live in a time of uh not that bright
politicians and we live in a time of bad
comedians our cultural taste makers
aren't being honest with us our
politicians are being honest with us and
then Along Comes This Tech guy who's
just trying to clean it up a little bit
and then you see how the mainstream
media reacts I'm not even telling you
that that interviewer was so horrible
like he wasn't he wasn't like
unbelievably horrible uh but the idea
that he's questioning Elon because
elon's just trying to open up the books
just trying to go oh the government was
working with Twitter to censor people
people have been Shadow banned and
everything else and now we are finding
out that more and more of what we were
told was definitely true like Russia
collusion all these years yeah it was
all complete nonsense
[Music]
foreign